there are new outtakes from the set of
that movie that Alec baldon worked on
where he shot and killed that woman the
cinematographer and the outtakes seem to
show and they're being promoted by NBC
which obviously is a company that Alec
baldman has worked for for much of his
career uh their outtakes that seem to
show that Baldwin was in fact concerned
about some of the safety measures or
lack thereof on the set and that he
didn't he expressed his concern he
didn't want to shoot toward the
cinematographer the cinematography
should not should should not have been
standing the line of fire she should
have been probably looking at a monitor
off in the other direction uh and forget
about the cinematographer for a second
that tragedy that she was killed there
were so many steps along the way so many
uh safety malfunctions that occurred
before Alec baldman pulled that trigger
here he is and everyone need to be right
here like in the path of the gun could
you please move just want to be over him
a little bit so I can see now wait a
second if I'm going to shoot right you
want to go on the other side of the
camera I don't want to shoot toward you
so there you see him look the Alec
Baldwin's a total Pro and he's there as
an actor and he's saying I don't want to
shoot towards you but apparently they
continued in this Reckless way anyway on
the set and here's a really unpopular
opinion this is going to be unpopular
opinion Monday
[Music]
here it's not Baldwin's fault Alec
Baldwin is not responsible for the
shooting on the rust set I know
instantly what people are going to say
is if you have a a firearm is always
your responsibility what happens with
that firearm if you have a firearm and
you're pointing it at
someone then you need to be ready to
kill that person that you want you have
to be ready to destroy whatever you're
pointing at that's basic firearm safety
101 and that's all true but that's not
movie making 101 movie making if you're
using a gun in a movie it almost always
involves you pointing it and shooting it
at somebody it is not
comparable the the the rules and
regulations you would follow at a gun
range or for any person in regular life
using a firearm it is not comparable to
the way that actors use firearms in
movies and Alec Baldwin here is an actor
the people who are responsible primarily
it's the
armorer the the weapons Master on the
set who was some clueless young girl who
obviously didn't know what she's doing
and the result is that a woman's now
dead the second person responsible would
be the first ad the first assistant
director who goes gets the weapon should
also be checking to make sure there it's
not load at all hands it to the actor
the third group responsible I guess
would be the producers and the crew onet
and technically Alec Baldwin is a
producer here but it's it's only a
technicality he's a producer as a common
Financial workaround for how to pay his
acting contract but he's not he's not
actually a producer in the way that in
the way that producers produce films
he's an actor primarily in the movie and
everyone's going after him because he's
a jerk and nobody likes him and I know
but I this is my my unpopular view throw
tomatoes at me I'm here to tell you the
truth I'm not here to Pander to you okay
they're going after Alec baldman because
he's an easy target because he is a rich
famous straight white guy who has a
legendary temper and he's just easy to
attack and it's a lot easier to put the
blame on him than on this clueless
armorer whose fault it actually
is
but I if if he were just an unknown
actor very few people would actually be
blaming him for this
I got listen don't ever accuse me of
just carrying water or reciting talking
points guys I'm defending Alec Baldwin
who was a very unlikable liberal but in
this case it's the way it is right now
go to genucell.com letter y letter T our
friends at genus cell have launched a
new product called genus cell 3 which
works fast on your under eye bags and
puffiness genus cell 3 is smoother more
luxurious and it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
for instant hydration it is like
Gatorade for your skin this new genus
cell technology keeps your skin looking
young and healthy for years to come the
genus cell fall Classics package also
includes a jawline treatment for a more
firm neck and jawline it also includes
Jus cell's anti- wrinkle moisturizer and
deep Firming Serum get your skin ready
for the cold and dry weather if you
don't look and feel your absolute best
you will get your money back no
questions asked go to jus.com nyt or you
can call 800 skin skin 211 for extra
discounts on this amazing fall package
results in 12 hours or the immedia
effects are included for free by the way
the founder of this company great Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left there for
the American dream so head on over to
jus.com letter y letter T or call 800
skin SK i n 211 the Department of
Education is now investigating seven
schools seven colleges and universities
including three Ivy League schools
for alleged incidents of anti-Semitism
and
anti-muslim
harassment those schools
include La Fayette Welsley wasn't
Welsley the school that what's her face
went to that my cousin Hillary Clinton
went to I think so Cooper Union
and uh Public School District in Kansas
so not even just the colleges and
universities and then of the Ivy League
schools Columbia Cornell and
upen now this is obviously a problem at
these campus I was just at Cornell and I
was at Cornell one week after some kid
threatened to murder all the Jews on
campus and slit the throats of the
Jewish men and do all sorts of
unspeakable things to the Jewish women
and even was threatening Jewish babies
and it was really I mean this is real
I'm not denying that this is real there
are obviously threats and harassment
against Jewish students for sure
and the D the doe is trying to be
evenhanded here and they're saying we're
going to investigate anti-islamic
incidents too I haven't seen seen a ton
of those I haven't heard about a lot of
those but I don't know maybe those are
happening too I'm not I'm not going to
say that they're certainly not happening
and both of those things certainly
should be investigated and absolutely
I'm all I am fine with the state going
after these big bloated schools that are
little more than indoctrination centers
for leftism but I got to
ask what about the anti-christian
harassment I'm not denying in any way
that there is anti-jewish harassment and
I'm somewhat skeptical but I'm willing
to grant that there's anti-islam
harassment but what about the
anti-christian harassment and if you're
going to look at this from a racial
point point of view if you're saying
well they're attacking the Jews because
the Jews are a tribe or they're
attacking the Muslims because they're
Arab and there's anti-arab sentiment
okay yeah maybe there is I I don't deny
any of that what about the anti-white
sentiment which is pervasive at all of
these schools there's one big
distinction between these various types
the anti-jewish the anti-muslim the
anti-arab versus the anti-christian and
often the anti-white the big distinction
is in the former category those
incidents are kids or towns
people Ju Just vandalizing things I
don't know you know drawing swastikas
and offhanded comment here or there in
the case of the anti-christian and
anti-white harassment that's coming from
the classrooms okay and those incidents
are not happening late at night at an
off-campus party or through vandalism on
a dorm room wall the anti-christian and
anti-white harassment is coming from the
faculty and the administration it's
coming from professors who say that we
need to abolish whiteness that that's a
goal worth pursuing it's coming from the
professors in the administration who are
decrying Christianity is an awful
imperialist religion that's completely
bogus anyway and even if it weren't
bogus has led to all sorts of terrible
things through all of human
history that's a big distinction and I'm
opposed to all of
it yeah keep that I I love it keep that
investigation up of the anti-islam even
and the anti-Semitism and sure keep
those investigations up when are we it's
not going to be under the Biden
Administration but when are we going to
have
the political coones and the correct
moral vision and the spine let's talk
about other anatomical features that are
a little closer to the intellect when
are we going to have the courage and the
moral Clarity to stand up against that
because that is the kind of harassment
that is happening with the official
sanction of the universities the
professors and the administrators what a
great clip that was now hey whoa whoa
whoa ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael NS YouTube channel see you next
time